all right i'm back with our very special
guest co-host to sean carter newman
you're doing so great usually you and i
would be sitting right there talking but
right now we're keeping our distance now
it's been almost a year since you've won
how has life been
life has changed dramatically so what
has been the biggest change i mean the
fans must be coming to you talking to
you about it you became a celebrity
i wouldn't say celebrity but really well
known you know like i get to meet lots
of new people i'm getting to know i'm
getting to build a bunch of new
relationships and it's been so much fun
like i can't put into words how much fun
i've had since i've left the house all
right let's talk about some of the
relationships that are different when
you come outside the house
how are you with jed jed jeff's my guy
that's my vote for life we always will
be undercover brothers we still keep in
touch but i haven't seen him that much
what about that beth i haven't seen beth
at all but i still talk to her i still
always have love for beth she was one of
my best friends in the house as well and
finally braden i love braden but i
haven't seen him in a while so i'm
really curious i don't know he's all the
way out west i haven't spoken to him in
a bit either but again we had such a
great relationship in the house and i've
cherished that forever and do you miss
anything about living in the house i
mean there's an experience there i mean
once you came out did you kind of say oh
i want to go back into the house no no
that must have been something you missed
about it i miss nothing about being in
the house you know what i miss the
people like the experience the people
and really getting to know people at
that intimate level is what i really
love but beyond that i don't miss being
actually physically in there i have a
little bit of ptsd maybe oh
you know what's so great also the fact
that you won after arisa cox really
spoke up about making changes and have
representation you were the first black
winner which
means so much i mean for you to be part
of this change must be so important to
you i think it's so important you know
what before i went on the show my mom
said you have to represent something
bigger than yourself yeah and bigger
than winning and i think in that season
we're able to to do that and establish
that and i think it was powerful for a
lot of people to see all over the
country i think it's powerful for even
potential future house guests to see
people who look like you in the house
and to see people that look like you on
tv means the world all right tisha we'll
have much more with you coming up but
right now let's continue to hear from
the season 10 house guests and find out
what kind of personalities they may or
may not get along with